une ville ravagée est toujours assiégée
par les russes depuis plus d'un mois à
marioupol 40% des bâtiments ont été
détruits selon la mairie dont des
hôpitaux des écoles ou encore des
crèches plus d'électricité ni d'eau
potable la situation est catastrophique
pour les habitants pris au piège qui
attend d'être évacués
cent mille habitants sont encore sur
place et ont besoin de cette évacuation
mais la ville est encerclée par les
troupes russes ils ne veulent pas ouvrir
les corridors humanitaires vers
l'intérieur de l'ukraine il ne les
laisse pas partir via ses couloirs des
couloirs humanitaires demandé aussi par
la france la grèce et la turquie paris
exige également la levée du siège de
marioupol l'autorisation pour les civils
qu'ils le veulent de quitter la ville
ainsi que l'acheminement d'une aide
humanitaire
lors d'un échange téléphonique avec
emmanuel macron vladimir poutine a posé
une condition à l'évacuation en toute
sécurité des civils pour trouver une
solution à la situation humanitaire
difficile dans cette ville les
combattants nationalistes ukrainiens
doivent arrêter de résister et déposer
les armes pour l'elysée les éléments ne
sont pas réunis à ce stade pour lancer
une opération humanitaire à destination
des habitants de marioupol au moins 5000
d'entre eux ont trouvé la mort depuis le
début de la guerre